She's got like the normal woman debuff. They watch that video
and they're like, "Oh my god, it's like Rust." And Nick was like,
"This guy stabbed me in the neck." When he [snorts] calls you
an F'sler, that's not bad faith. He really thinks that, okay?
You were stretching the out of your cheeks in order to stuff
it in there.
Oh, hold on. I do actually, before you go, the chorus stuff,
you followed that whole thing with Taylor Lorenz as well, again.
Oh, dude, that was so frustrating, yeah. And I got a link to
your stream saying that I'm funded by some Qatari Qatari person,
which is very silly and not true. Is your Are you telling me
that the LLC is solely funded by Pierre? I would imagine yes,
because that's how we're able to take part in the program. >> fact
that you would say I would imagine seems to necessitate you using
your imagination, and the reason why you have to use your imagination
is because it's dark, because you don't know. And so, I don't
think that Destiny is necessarily actually stating that this
is a dark money group. I think he's pretending to be an idiot
to to listen to her make a bunch of points that are untrue again
in their conversation, and Destiny miss on all of the things
that are actually untrue, and keep pushing on the things that
are that he's wrong on. Like Like his claims on the [__]
media archetypes. Like he is he is just wrong. Like Omidyar does
not qualify as dark money, not under her definition, not under
anybody's definition. It just does not qualify as dark money
at all. >> I think Destiny's getting confused. That It's
like It sucks cuz like and I I don't mean this is a like I'm
not trying to [__] on her. She just doesn't know
how to like debate somebody on the internet like Destiny. But
she's bright. She's like correct, but she doesn't even know how
to formulate that she's correct. So, like he's able to extract
things that look like wins to people who can't pay attention.
Like very frustrating to
Very annoying to watch. >> she's got like the normal woman
debuff of like every conversation that a woman
Like always running the risk of coming across as being like
I mean, to put it bluntly, um, coming across really condescending
or really >> that. She leans into that which is very funny.
I love it. I love it. No, I that that actually might be my favorite
part where she was just like, "Oh, I'm sorry that you like really
don't understand right now. Let me try to explain it to you.
I'll just try to break it down for you a little bit." and
No, I I love that. I know that gamers I know that gamers really
want sources, but that's not how we do it in the in the journalism
world, Destiny. You don't >> Twitch I don't know how your
little Twitch sphere works. I don't know how that works. Yeah.
Good stuff. Good stuff. >> Dude, I was afraid of that when
she was saying that. I don't know. That was like an AoE effect.
But yeah, I mean, we're to the point now where uh, some people
are trying to defend Destiny on this take did not realizing that
Destiny has about to say he does not have a definition of, uh,
dark money. But if he does have a definition, Taylor Lorenz falls
within it. And also, surprise, surprise, by the way, his definition
includes LLCs.
He literally He literally just thinks all commerce is dark money.
Like this is essentially what his position is. It's [__]
stupid. I said the exact same thing. The entire economy is dark
money to Destiny. And it always has been.
Dude, I I'm just going to have my mind listening to this stuff.
To me, dark money has always meant 501c4.
That is dark money. But now, like half of the internet politics
communities are running around saying that everything is dark
money. And nobody knows what it [__] means
But the sad thing is all the people doing that are people with
like who are in Chorus or friends with people in Chorus or some
some thing like Chorus. And so it's like I just wish I wish they
could just be honest cuz the honest answer is Republicans are
doing this so we want to do it, too.
Yeah. fine. But just say that. And don't don't call me a liar
or say I'm disingenuous for pointing out that you're wrong.
That's I just find it how these people are like bleating and
crying,
begging Taylor Lorenz to cover dark money on the right. She technically
has covered dark covered dark money on the right every time that
she's talking about a Republican receiving a paycheck. That's
all dark money.
Every time that you talk about a political influencer being paid,
it's dark money. Or even a journalist, anybody. Anybody can receive
dark money. By By those definitions, sure sure sure sure. Yeah.
Yeah. Like people asking for more investigation on the right,
and now they've got no clue what the [__] they're
even asking for. So, none and it's all because Destiny wanted
to say that Taylor Lorenz received dark money to slag her off
offhandedly on a [__] live stream, and then defend
it in the most dishonest way possible. It is all based on like
spite for Taylor Lorenz. These people have just like abandoned
a huge talk of talk of a political conversation. They cannot
talk about it
And the funny thing is is I'm sure he's found a way to try to
twist something into a win out of that conversation. That's probably
why he wants to talk to her again after looking into things.
And it's just like it's so sad having the kind of political engagement
where you get into a fight with somebody, you argue with them,
you lose, and then you're like, "Now I'm going to research this.
Now I'm going to go figure out how all this works."
Third conversation.
Yeah, third conversation coming up.
And what I I what I think people have lost sight of as well,
I I've even lost sight of it when I was doing coverage, the original
allegation for why Taylor Lorenz was taking dark money is because
the Omedi on network, their 501c4,
I believe, had received money from
Omedi on network services LLC. It was a just an LLC.
Yes. Yeah. They received money from 1630.
So, it's like, "Oh, okay. You received money that's filled by,
you know, you know, the guys that you were trying to critique
right now." Which A would maybe point towards like dark money
not working, given the fact that she's received the money and
is still criticizing the organization.
Um, which certainly would be a journalist. >> said Yeah,
like an interest there obviously vested. Like Pierre Omidyar
I wouldn't be shocked if he literally is one of the people investing
in Chorus. Like I wouldn't be shocked.
he clearly in likes that kind of investing to begin with. Like
this is This is basically criticizing, like you said, a specific
thing that they would support if not directly, like spiritually,
right? >> Yeah. Anyway, continue.
But yeah, the original allegation was that she was taking dark
money because the people that funded her were funded by dark
money. Now, the whole reason why they came out in their statement
and said that the reporters and residents program is not funded
by the 1630 fund. That was because of the initial allegation.
Did they receive this big pot of money and were like dishing
it out? So, assuming it's presumably the money that they received
has been tied by a grant to like specific payouts or specific
programs.
And the the reporters and residents thing wasn't attached to
that. So, that's why that wasn't established in the first disclosure.
But people have lost sight of what what the original allegation
even was. And with no idea, they're running around with a vague
sense that maybe Taylor Lorenz has taken dark money. If you ask
these to spell out why they think that or what kind of crumb,
tiny scrap of evidence has led them to that
they won't be able to point to it cuz we've fallen so far away
from the original allegation.
Do you know what the best part is? You I've I've cuz I've had
this conversation like three or four times now.
It's not even that they can't point to evidence. I literally
go, "Okay, I'll give you I'll do you one better.
Fantasize. Literally, come up with something that could plausibly
explain how or why she's taking dark money here. Literally, just
tell me explain to me because the for it to be dark money, you're
suggesting that Pierre Omidyar is lying, he's not the sole funder
himself,
So, give me any situation every any scenario you could plausibly
come up with that you think that you would you would bet any
amount of money on that could explain this. And there isn't.
There is nothing. There's nothing that explains why a billionaire
would suddenly take money from other people to go into his trust,
his LLC, his thing that he explicitly funds himself, right? So,
that he can make all the call all the shots. Like, there is no
scenario you can make up. You could fantasize and you can't come
up with a scenario, let alone have evidence for something that
explains this or points in that direction. And that's crazy to
me. Like, I don't know if you want to give it a shot. Could you
fantasize a situation where that could happen? Just try it. A
billionaire has got a particular project that they would want
to fund with charitable donations to be able to make a change
on the political or journalistic landscape. And there is another
person who owns or operates a dark money fund who also has a
similar interest. Pierre Omidyar maybe has some specialty in
navigating or organizing this stuff. Maybe the project has already
already started to kind of wind up. So, okay, cool. Let's bucket
our but kind of pull our efforts. You send me some money and
then I can grow this into like a bigger program than I originally
That's one way that I can imagine it happening. So, okay.
Pierre Omidyar has direct connections to the 1630 Fund, which
is a 501c4. That other billionaire doesn't want to be named.
First of all, if that billionaire doesn't mind being named, he
could just give a contribution to the 501c3,
right? Directly. Uh-huh. If that billionaire doesn't want to
be named, then Pierre Omidyar already has connections to 1630
who could do he could just spin up his own 501c4. They could
do it that way. Because I believe to take So, the way Destiny's
thinking about this is they take money's they would take money
in through the LLC, which would incur, if it's a gift, I do believe
that incurs like it is income for the company.
And so, it incurs taxes. That's the whole point of the 501c4
three or 501c4,
right? So, that Sorry, I didn't I didn't add that in as a part
of my thing, but that's usually how I would introduce it to people
is it's like they cuz Destiny's suggesting that the five the
LLC is what's there and um hidden. Cuz the 501c3 everybody has
to fill up their names or whatever, right? So, where is he getting
money in? Okay, through the LLC. Well, that's taxable.
So, they're going to lose what? How much money does he If it's
not that much money, he could cover it himself. If it is that
much money, obviously it'd be worth it to spin up a 501c4 of
your own.
Do it through with a with 1630s a fiscal sponsor or
just do it through 1630 in general. Like, do you know what I
mean? There's just no logical reason that he would take money
in through this LLC.
No, yeah, yeah, 100%. Like, it's it's going to get taxed in a
way that it just never needs to be. Um I'm pretty sure that you
can just donate directly to the Omidyar Network uh 501c4
and just do it that way as well. If you want to remain remain
anonymous.
The Omidyar Network is a 501c3.
They have a 501c4, I believe. Is that Is that what Network Services
is? Maybe?
Uh Omidyar Family Disclosures 501c4. Family Disclosures
501c4
It's 501c4. Oh, this would be their disclosures to I think 501c4s
they donate to.
Oh wait, really? Um publish their 501c4 donations annually. So,
this would be donations to things that they would
Cuz the Omidyar Network is a 501c
3 foundation.
And it says a 501c4 advocacy group. Oh,
cuz I do think Wait, is it Wait, when did they have cuz I I could
have sworn they did not have a 501c4 attached here. But maybe
our network's 501c3 LLC hybrid, but does the immediate group
contain some 501c4 in it that they also do work with? You might
be right. I might have misconstrued a part of this.
So the Well, the 501c3 that's why it's so funny is because like
literally
there's there's just
nothing nothing explained to you makes sense to call this dark
money.
Lauren's or for the on Taylor's front,
it's it's just funny that um I think the only reason this is
still up in the air is cuz she's just not used to arguing this
stuff directly.
There's there are subsidiaries that might be 501c4s like actual
charity orgs. Sure, and I do think to donate to 501c4s, I think
they do that through their LLC.
But again, this whole thing that the thing that pays out all
of their grants and stuff, it's all just Pure Media's
And there's just no reason to believe that there's another person
in here mixing their money into the pot.
Yeah, you're right. I've misconstrued the the 501c4 disclosures
thing. Okay. I mean, that makes it even more
Yeah, it does. It really does.
Damn, man. I what Dude, I just don't I just don't [__]
get it. 501c4 disclosures, they literally disclose what 501c4
like they they disclose everything they Dude, they're like so
transparent about everything. The idea that these are the people
lying, it just doesn't make any sense. It's like it's demanding
like it's it's expecting a level of um or analyzing something
at a level of scrutiny that makes no sense. Right? Like By the
way, at the best you could do here, by the way, is make Taylor
almost as bad as Chorus, but also Taylor like disclosed on her
end, so it's still not as bad as Chorus. So even if you felt
like this is maybe another massive massively frustrating thing
to me is they're not measuring Taylor by her they're not doing
an internal critique of Taylor's position her position on dark
money they're not giving even their own critique they've like
invented a third extremely like harsh definition an extremely
like all-encompassing definition of dark money to apply to her
specifically
Yeah the sheen never goes is like fundamentally dishonest
from the beginning
Yeah goofy
I mean some people have
some people have been more or less honest about it I saw that
I saw that Tom Fuller was going to make a video a few months
ago about the chorus stuff and that just never came to fruition
I
What you say? Oh
I will have a question for you about that cuz I don't know if
you saw the fact that 1630 probably wasn't the funder of this
but that seemed wild to me given how the original drama played
out You know what I'm talking about? >> The original funder
of this
the chorus they're they're like not the funder of chorus that
that's not really how they work
Wait what? I I was was chorus not explicitly designed as a as
a child of the 1630 fund or initiative of the 1630
The way the way these things work the way the 1630 fund works
is basically they give you they they fiscally sponsor you is
the way they describe it which means you basically get to go
through them become like a a child 501c4 under and they like
set up the way your like payments work and stuff but I do believe
you're still responsible for getting the money yourself so the
project sources the funding Like other fiscal sponsor 1630 fund
is not the original source of funding for the projects it incubates
when a founder or funder makes a donation to support a project
fiscal sponsor receives the donation on behalf of the project
1630 fund follows all local state and federal law with respect
to the disclosure of individual donors
So basically you let people donate to the 1630 Fund. Like Like
basically they set up all the donations up. They handle all the
filings, all the disclosures that need to be made. They handle
all the compliance, everything you need to do, but you just have
to worry about like running your project and then soliciting
your donors, getting the money sent, right?
But that implies that somebody else was the funder.
And so some
If I'm understanding this correctly then, what you're saying.
So, somebody somebody else has donated it. And when they give
a donation to Chorus, they actually write out to the 1630 Fund.
And then 1630 writes it out to the respective contractors or
>> They'll actually pay the contractors. So, that's why
the 1630 Fund is on the contractor. Or sorry, is on the contractor's
checks.
Oh my god. Okay, I'm understanding that a little bit more now.
So, the weirdest thing in the world to me is the way it's reported
was 1630 Fund was funding it. And what she makes no difference
on how it's dark money. It's dark money either way. I don't know
why nobody challenged that cuz it kind of like if they wanted
to try to discredit the reporting, they could have just gone
like the 1630 Fund doesn't fund anything. You're stupid.
And I think that would have been more effective than almost any
other statement they made. So, I don't understand how nobody
pointed that out when they were going to defend Chorus this whole
time. Tom Forelli pointed this out and I was like, "Oh, what
the
My intuition from that is that 1630 possibly did give them financial
Cuz I know that they Cuz Taylor Lorenz spoke about a time from
what I remember, there being like rounds of funding. And she
was able to get a hold of some of the initial kind of like fundraising
um
But if nobody came out and said that 1630 doesn't pay us at all,
I I I'd imagine that 1630 maybe made a contribution themselves.
so the idea I'm getting is that they actually don't really take
contributions, they take on projects. What I think probably is
the case, I'm guessing there's some reason they do it this way.
Probably keep donors like donors' names hush-hush or something.
But I'm guessing they actually pair funders with donors, uh sorry,
funders with projects. That like they probably take projects
on and they probably help the people run their like pitch decks
for the the funders and stuff like that. And so it seems like
the way it works with the 1630 fund is they don't just take in
a lot of base funding at this point. They take in funding for
specific projects.
I think. Huh. I'm not sure. So
But I What I don't understand is how nobody pointed out this
whole thing.
And again, it doesn't really like the article is still
categorically correct. It's just like one of the claims is that
the 1630 fund is the dark money group funding it. Well, I guess
the I would suppose that the only people who would have who would
be privy to that information would be incredibly high up at Chorus.
And so they've got a decision. You can either go in there and
request a like some kind of correction, which is basically meaningless
and kind of kind of like vicariously confirms a lot of the other
reporting.
Like for example, if Tyler Tyler Bryant Bryant Icom were to go
in there and say, "I'm actually correction,
uh you spelled my name wrong." It's like, "Okay, cool. So everything
else that was said here is correct." Or he can leave no correction
there and walk away with being like, "This is not true. This
is not true." Do you know what I mean? Whine about whine about
it in public and then yeah.
To his audience, yeah.
That's the way that I imagine it going.
Sometimes it's better to not request for a correction.
When you don't when you can't correct like the That's why I think
they have a ground with it is because the stuff on the contracts.
Okay, but why not say it publicly then? That's That's actually
maybe the bigger thing is why when he made his Twitter video
did he not say
Maybe because nobody would would have really cared.
It's like such a minor thing. You were still getting dark money.
It's just like whose pockets is it coming from? >> to the
article. Is it foundational to the critique?
No, but nobody can even understand that.
You don't think so? Huge Democrat group not allowing people to
disclose their >> it. I don't I think I genuinely think
that if you if you did that, people go, "Yeah, well, it's like
sort of the central Did she really do any work if she could get
her central thesis incorrect?"
I I it's I swear I feel like that could easily happen, but maybe
I've lost too much faith in humanity at this point. It is inconsequential
for the like the substance of the critique though. I agree.
I I um
I'm not sure if
Chorus is as worried about Taylor Lorenz as the creators are,
to be honest. Uh Could be. Yeah. Yeah, I don't think Chorus is
concerned with so much. I think it's like their own PR.
So, I think Taylor has intimated a lot of people won't work with
Chorus at this point. Or are skeptical about Chorus creators
because they're kind of marred with dark money and what they
can and can't talk about. Cuz they won't That was the big narrative,
right? Wasn't so much about exactly where the funding was coming
from cuz nobody's got anything really bad to say about 1630.
I can disclose it from a bunch of creators who claim to be independent
and aren't saying they're getting paid to go to these meetings
and do all this other
But it was also the implication that there was maybe some What
would it even be? Some like
uh political ideology
homogeneity?
People given certain talking points? Certain types of creators
being paid? Seemed like a slush fund for Zionists was the I think
the uh the outrage on Twitter that day, right?
That was the outrage on Twitter. >> came from. That's not
from the article and I had this argument with people. I I think
it was improper of Taylor to retweet some some people who suggested
this much. And for I think she kind of fed into this as well.
I don't think it like mars the article at all, but I do think
she shouldn't have gone and supported like those narratives herself.
It's I think it's what she thinks though. I do think she probably
thinks that like they weren't concerned with like giving a lot
of, you
a lot of Palestinian voices money.
I Yeah, I don't know how else to say that. No, I think I I think
I probably agree, but I'm saying it if Crooked were worried about
some kind of reputational backslide, I think that's where they
would be concerned.
the idea that they're like trying to push a very niche leftist
idea.
Or a very kind of partisan
kind of internally partisan leftist idea to the exclusion of,
as she pointed out in her article, people like Hasan [__]
who weren't invited.
I think that critique is very subtly in there in the article.
She points out Hasan not being there, and it's very obvious why
she's saying that, I think. Well, obvious if you take everything
else into account. I think
it's like an implication there, sure.
If you had just So, I had seen >> I think the article stands,
but I'm I'm saying like knowing Taylor Lorenz, yeah.
I think before I'd seen some of the stuff going on like around
it, I hadn't gotten this implication. And then I watched like
I think one of one of these she had with Glenn Greenwald where
she basically said it's as much as like it's a Zionist slush
fund. I think And then I was like, "Oh." And then I had it pointed
out to me and I'm like, "Ah, I kind of see it now." Now like
knowing Taylor and seeing some of the stuff that's outside of
the article, yeah,
But yeah, all that aside, feel as though I feel as though that
was the big reputational hit, and that's what they were trying
to avoid. I don't think any of the reputational hit was like,
"Well, the 1630 Fund is funding you." I think even she points
out in her article it kind of supports a lot of noble causes
that she agrees with. Yeah, that she doesn't disagree with that.
Yeah, yeah, sure, sure.
Yeah. Yeah. But that that kind of answers it for me. If it is
true that 1630 isn't the main funder of this, I understand why
they never asked for a correction. Okay. Yeah. I man, I still
think it cuz I I don't think they've really responded to the
substance of the article anyway.
And so I feel like um I feel like their responses were kind of
goofy already. I feel like this feels like it has a little bit
more weight, but maybe not. Like I just I don't see why he didn't
bring it up basically.
Yeah. But I mean what I think what I was saying before is it's
crazy how many people in the Destiny orbit kind of knew the story
and broke rank to say what Destiny's saying is not correct actually.
Um the one person that I was surprised didn't break rank, I was
surprised that Connor broke rank. Obviously given the Destiny's
actually really smart. Steven's really smart. This is a ploy.
He's pretending to be stupid here actually. I kind of expected
that to some degree. What who I didn't expect to be on the Destiny
train was Lonerbox.
Cuz he wrote an Obsidian article that you can still find on Google
if you Google Taylor Lorenz O'Medialist in the first search result.
>> Yeah, literally it's literally in my thing, yeah.
Yeah, yeah. Talking about all of it. >> Sorry, that's what
I mean.
Like dude, you you know what went on here and then you're listening
to Destiny talk about it. It's like you're buying into everything
that he's saying. Like what he's saying is not true. It's not
correct that Taylor Lorenz is taking dark money. He's got an
entire section on it in this article.
I I think he thought that Taylor I think he agreed with the argument
that Taylor Lorenz was taking dark money. I think that's when
he wrote this. I do believe he was saying in his stream that
Taylor Lorenz was taking dark money.
As much as he wrote out a bunch of the stuff here, he wrote like
notes on it.
I do think he He basically That seems to be the definition used
by Taylor is 1630 is also a nonprofit and therefore does not
require disclose donors. Therefore, not required to disclose
donor disclose
Oxford Languages funds raised for the purpose of influencing
elections by nonprofit organizations that are not required to
disclose the identities of their donors.
What is dark money? But go down to where it starts with Omidyar.
So there's a Omidyar is like a sub-bullet here.
Hybrid structure
We aim to empower journalists.
Ex-journalists summer 2025 reporters maintain full editorial
control and discretion over their work is a quote. No funding
received for this. Suggest their programs are funded by the LLC
and the 501c3.
Cayman Islands question mark NY Mag article suggesting Omidyar
funneled money through the Cayman Islands base through a Cayman
Islands based private equity fund. What are you talking about
here? What were you looking for?
Well, I'm saying he already knows the disclosure that's gone
if it's like happened. So he's followed the entire story and
so he presumably knows the initial allegation was that they were
taking money from 1630.
And then they say explicitly here, we are not taking money by
1630.
That's what he
That's what he puts in quotation marks. Right. Sure, but I think
he's basically I think he agreed with the argument
that because you couldn't see the source. Like I think that's
I think he's the one I think Destiny took this point from him.
Or somebody in his chat like in in the chats gave the point to
Destiny. Cuz I think this was the point
Lonerbox was making originally. Was that it's essentially dark
money because you can't see where the funding is coming
I feel like that's the case and maybe somebody could correct
that if that's wrong. But that's the impression I got.
Mhm, maybe.
>> I I do think that Lunar Box was more on that side. I
wasn't that shocked that he
ended up continuing to say that Taylor took dark money. Okay.
Right? I think it kind of all comes down to
Yeah, I man, now I actually wonder. Now I kind of want to look
it up and see.
I might have to do that at some point. You watch any Have you
followed any of that fight between um Lunar Box and Queenman?
I just I just don't think it's going to happen, is it? It's just
not going to happen. Oh, no, I don't think so. I don't think
so. I just wish I just wish um as with many many pe- people,
okay? I just wish they could say what they actually mean with
Queenman. He's actually just a and I don't want to talk to him
cuz he's an a
Like not saying oh, he he's bad faith. No, when he calls you
an F'sler, that's not bad faith. He really thinks that, okay?
It's not bad faith when he just calls you mean names.
It'd be bad faith if he said some disingenuous argument that
he didn't really believe. I know that that's what I know that
that's what Lunar Box
Oh, sorry. I know that's charac- Queenman's characterization
of Lunar Box. Do you think that's what Lunar Box means when he
says that Queenman's bad faith? I mean, I'm just using the meaning
of bad faith.
I think I think he's saying bad faith. And I I think he means
that Queenman's an a
Basically, yes. Okay.
Um What do you What do you think? >> I'm not going for
any any particular side. I think what he means is he's talking
about like >> Well, hold on. I'll give Well, wait, wait,
wait. I'll give one one slightly better. Is I think Queenman
spends a little too much time harping on
like where Lunar Box might have misspoken and not thinking enough
about
like if Lunar Box were an intelligent actor, what he might mean
in a situation. He doesn't spend a lot of time positively building
up Lunar Box. He just spends time like tearing down
Lunar Box, right?
That's maybe the best >> Yeah, I think
I think that's that's what I got from Lunar Box's coverage when
he was talking about it. He got very very annoyed cuz he thought
that Queenman wasn't
taking him seriously enough
or something like that or he felt he was giving like uncharitable
readings to what he was saying. Obviously, I think Queenman is
just like riffing
and he's trying to basically mock Luna
He's just taking the piss.
But yeah, I think that's what Luna Box is talking about there.
I don't think it's the insults. Wasn't Queenman Queen was insulting
him all the way back when they had the first conversation, right?
>> Not the way he was recently. And also Luna Box there's
a couple of other little random comments in there that are you
know, I watch some of this stuff sometimes. I've seen I've seen
comments like this before. What what What is actually happening
is Luna Box is like
really hate me and Queenman and will watch all of her stuff just
so they can see then clip like one moment and send it to him
or put it in a Discord
so they can like picture themselves
and that's like all he gets to see, right? Are those moments.
And so he gets like a different impression. But he had little
comments about how oh, you know, some of the stuff that doesn't
go to main channel videos and Queen was much nicer to Luna before.
Yeah, he was definitely.
He used to be defensive of Luna Box. I lasted way way I mean,
I'm still defensive of Luna Box, but I lasted way longer than
Queenman. I don't know. Now he kind of just lets his Discord
spread a rumor that I'm like really anti-Semitic, which I feel
like is is wrong, to be honest. I feel like it's sort of the
exact thing he said complained to like Hutch about. I do find
it a little odd
like the exact thing he complained or or said, you know, Hutch
had a good point with Pisco that that's the exact exact thing
that happens to me and his Discord and it's just not a problem,
I guess, but you know, I hey, but Queenman gave Queenman gave
some charity to what Luna Box might mean, right? Like he he did.
It just wasn't a lot.
Yeah. And yeah, like you said, I think there's a some amount
of like it's just he's just trying to laugh and make fun of him
for a live stream. Make it entertaining.
Yeah. Yeah. Shame it's not going to happen though.
Man, have you thought about talking >> of the Hasan tweet?
Slater Box? I asked him to talk the other day. He didn't want
to talk, so.
He was too sleepy. That's a shame. That's a shame. Um
Wait, he's in Scotland. It's still pretty dark up there to be
fair. There's like 4 hours of sun a day, so I could believe that.
Um yeah. He was in I think he was in some chat with like Hutch
or something. And
I can't remember what it was. I can understand why that would
make him sleepy, yeah.
He said he was becoming he was like obsessed with the people
who are obsessed with Hutch. And I was watching and saw him chat
that and I was like, "Hey, I'm I'm incredibly obsessed with Hutch.
Do you want to come on stream and talk about it? We can feed
that we can feed the demon both sides, okay?
You're obsessed with the people who are obsessed. I'm obsessed.
We should totally talk. >> called it sour at each other.
Trying to study at each other. Yeah. Yeah. No, I thought the
I thought the tweet was
uh just pretty
I couldn't help but cringe.
>> I mean, I'm not I I wouldn't even say I'm biased against
Slater Box. I mean, I know that a lot of people really don't
like the guy. Especially with Takes recently. I maybe have not
watched enough Slater Box to really know what I think about that,
but I you know, so I just to say I don't share the same
DUDE, I
>> MY MY TEETH WERE GRITTED READING THIS. Just the biggest
lefty streamer jumping on a
32 like tweet about me.
Cuz he's definitely above the slop.
I don't think Has he said Has he said that he's above the slop?
Or are people like being swined to pile in?
Uh I think he used to he used to say he was above.
Yeah, he used to say he was above this stuff. I think he's made
it pretty clear recently he's he's throwing elbows now,
Getting chippy.
I think this is all Listen, I'm pretty sure Hassan watches at
this point. I'm not 100% sure I'm pretty sure he watches though,
okay?
Cuz I went on a whole rant about how he has to get involved about
how he can't like sit back anymore and let people just like blind
him everywhere and that if he doesn't get involved he's like
supports some of the people or like the Mike from PA is the world
or whatever that like he's just going to get rolled over by people
who actually do.
And I swear to God like the same week he just started he started
tweeting everything. He started like retweeting people. He started
liking maybe Substance clips but no shutting him >> have
made it into the Asanover.
Uh no. No, I've definitely I
I think I still I can't help but snark him occasionally, okay?
There's definitely no way he's um be happy with me for long.
No. I just I laughed cuz he like started doing that right away.
>> you know?
With what? Big Twitch streamer probably got connections with
another big Twitch streamer, maybe. Those guys like each other,
don't they? I don't know. Maybe. They hate Teckton. That is for
sure. Yeah. It's just dude, when you're like screenshotting it
to then tweet about how like
he's responding to me.
>> Can you guys believe this? He's responding to me right
now.
The funny thing about this is it he's responding because he got
this tweet because Substance retweeted it.
That's like I didn't know how this happened. It was because Substance
retweeted this and he follows Substance.
That's how he ended up getting this. And he just thought it was
about Letterboxd and certainly was just like oh he he throws
replies on a bunch of little things like this now. Interesting.
You see Destiny crying about it? I I didn't. I assume he did,
yeah. Oh.
He sucks as the child kept hidden in the insane asylum when it
comes to being in the Hasan's orbit. Maybe. No, Substance he
definitely is an alt account that follows you 100%. I'm I'm positive
of
Some Some account he follows you on has the bell It's got the
bell turned on. He knows when you tweet.
I'm positive.
Sorry, I didn't see the other Letterbox tweet here. My stance
was pretty straightforward, but I'm yet to hear whether or not
@HasanAbi wanted the anti-regime protesters to win in January.
Should be a pretty easy answer,
Sure Hasan would rather the people be >> it or not.
Well, like I think is he implying
Maybe I'm crazy. Wouldn't Hasan just like say I want the people
to have the system that they want?
Like he said that for Taiwan.
I don't know why he wouldn't say that for Iran. I mean it's just
that what is Hasan even supposed to say in return to that? Yes,
I want the IOGC. Well, I think that's what he is assuming. Oh,
you got the Kaczynski follow? Let's go. I don't know, you got
the Kaczynski follow, Substance. That's based.
>> basically just saying like
uh I'm yet to hear whether or not Hasan wanted the anti-regime
protesters to win in January.
It's like, okay, do you want the IOGC in
installed right now or not?
It's like uh uh Yeah. Well, I think I think he's of the opinion
that it might just be the case that Hasan wants the IOGC, that
he likes the Islamic theocracy there. To be clear, >> actually
think that's true? No, but you also know that Hasan will be baited
into saying things he essentially doesn't believe because he
doesn't think it's a because he basically believes in not breaking
ranks on things, right?
Oh, sure. >> Like when he says he's 10 toes down with the
Houthis, I'm pretty sure he doesn't support civilian kidnapping
in any case.
But he still will be baited into saying 10 toes down with the
Houthis with no clarification because he thinks like giving like
basically can see he's talked about this at some point. I should
find this rant. But he think he has this like belief that if
you concede little things like that, you chip away at your own
position and so he will just maximally defend and then worry
about clarifying later. And so I do think sometimes people will
catch him like this. Now, I guess you could also say that's like
a way of making up for your own like misspeaks or your own like
what you you that your mask slipped or something.
Yeah, I don't know.
The Destiny rational for not condemning violence, maybe. I think
that he was supportive of the of the Houthis.
I don't think that's like a him overcommitting to his position.
I feel the way that he talks about the way that he
Uh-huh. 100%.
I'm saying that probably there are certain tactics that he would
go, "Oh, that's something they shouldn't do. I would disavow
that act."
But I don't disavow the Houthis. I don't think he would disavow
the Houthis in general because he believes they're helping fight
against Israel, right? It's like the the apartheid and the
I do think that like he might be against the acts specifically,
but he thinks like actually criticizing those acts instead of
you know, spending his his energy criticizing Israel's like a
or something like this. >> Uh possibly. >> I don't
deny it. When he's speaking Yeah, I just get the impression that
when he's speaking to the guy
Tim Houthi Shalameh
and when he's talking about the captain who's been kidnapped,
I just don't get the impression that he's like concerned about
the welfare. I just don't think that he's concerned about the
guys who were kidnapped.
Like I'm not loading a moral judge
They're Filipinos. >> were taken for their welfare. Yeah,
I
Yeah, that's probably true. >> to would my country and
I would say that I would be concerned for them if they got kidnapped,
you know?
Yeah, yeah.
That's I mean, that's basically how I
is like easily the worst thing I think that Hassan's done it
out of all the stuff. Like I always go back to people are like,
"Oh, you flipped all these positions." Like, "No, I still think
it's insane that he didn't care about these people from the Galaxy
leader getting kidnapped. Then he watched that video." And they're
like, "Oh my god, it's like Rust. It's like Rust."
These people kidnapped for like 18 months, by the way. Like held
in Yemen. The worst of the worst of hell holes, okay?
Realistically,
it No, I won't say it would have been better if they just shot
them, but it's not that far off, okay?
Having to spend a year in Yemen.
Hopefully they gave them some of that
You know what I'm talking about? The the stuff that you do with
the Yemeni people. Yeah? Okay. >> Yeah, yeah, yeah. That
[__] is supposed to be horribly
I do believe it is. That's a rough few weeks when you're back
in America. Is that the propaganda at the very end? Even makes
freedom taste less sweet. I think that's it. I think that's what
they're trying to do. You want to return to Yemen just for the
leaves. Send me back. Yeah, send me back.
Bro, what the [__] [laughter]
They fill up like a cheek.
They get a full cheek going every time.
Are you coping living in Yemen, okay?
Not great.
There was some areas of the UK where you can buy khat. Um, I
have never seen a guy with a hamster cheek full of the stuff,
though. What the [__] is that?
>> Yeah. It's like not even like a week like it's literally
just all over the place there.
It's just [__] It's load up, man. Oh, [__]
This is a way better one. Hold
You get a load of Get a load of this guy. Is it this prolific
right here?
He's got it loaded up. That's like too much. That your your mouth
is going to hurt after that.
Like you are actually so addicted to this leaf at this point.
You are stretching the out of your cheeks in order to stuff it
in there. Like look at the other cheek. That's not a cheekbone.
It's like sunken in cuz it's been stretched that bad. He's going
to get like trumpet as cheeks.
It won't hurt. It's a painkiller. Ah, it's true. That's true.
No pain.
I thought that it did like [__] up your Like what
Zyn's do. I heard it was like Zyn's but on like on like steroids.
I'm sure it does. I'm sure it must be pretty rough.
This is the same reaction we have to the shirts Dick wears on
[laughter] I What does that even mean? Oh, that looks painful.
Does he realize how painful that looks?
Oh. Oh, okay. Okay. I'm sorry. That's That was off the top of
my head. That might not be with Q Q man. I don't know. I don't
know. You could have just said you didn't know what what what
they meant but that's okay, too. I just guessed. I just guessed.
Q Q's throwing out some Romans. It must have been something like
that. I don't know what shirts he wears. So, I'm Hey, I'm just
Q Q wouldn't open his Do you think Q Q would have said something
nice? I just say the only way I knew he was insulting you is
that he was speaking.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah. I'm saying next time that you tell me that somebody thinks
you're anti-Semitic, I'll just start guessing about reasons why.
I'll just start start guessing about reasons why. Maybe it's
the constant videos >> Unfortunately, I do just keep giving
people reasons why. Yeah. I unfortunately do just keep giving
people reasons why.
That's not true, but
actual real reasons in the moment I am definitely loading up.
This is so real, though.
This is so real. Oh my Hate Barry Weiss. That [__]
This is so real. It's so What am I supposed to do?
I just wish I wish I had some non-anti-Semites who were this
real. You know what I'm saying? That's far. That's all we want.
That's all we want in the whole world. Some
some anti-Zionist people who could just be funny like this. God.
Kyle Kulinski with the with the
>> That's a lot of beads, you nasty [__]
Kyle Kulinski is probably the next best and yet still There's
there he's getting there. Dude, Kyle Kulinski You see how Kyle
Kulinski is doing Hasan's bad now?
Wait, what? What?
No, no, no. Sorry, I mean like he's pointing it out. Like he's
pointing out that people's entire political worldviews just a
Hasan bad.
Yeah, it's catching on. It's kind of unavoidable right now, especially
after the fever pitch that was created by the [__]
dog.
That [__] dog.
We need to move on. >> People People aren't ready to move
on. I think there was a post from today. By the way, Aawks got
to get back on his game. What happened? Do you think Do you think
the account was like being botted or something?
even in some of the best
like absolute best tweets he's got going.
He's got no motion on these.
I think for a while he got like um like insane amounts of reach
because nobody else was doing I guess the like similar things
that he was. Like you would have
kick clipper accounts who would like clip through a very kind
of kind of niche section of streamers. Probably realistically
cuz you get they were getting paid by them, right? But I feel
like I see like a thousand people now trying to do the Aawks
stuff.
And so he just gets like crowded out.
Yeah, maybe.
I think there was a few months of time where people would like
go to Aawks for their like streaming news. Like that was the
Twitter account to go to. And now there's like a million different
ones. Yeah. There are
I feel like he's still got a lot of views on some things.
I don't know I don't know how to make sense of like his metrics
sometimes. I think some of the stuff is probably bought. Yeah.
The Hasan stuff still does well. I just thought Sorry, I was
going to scroll these replies really quickly cuz I do think a
lot of this is um son in the dog
get about Israel. Get about Israel. Bro, I can't believe people
react to the the the Sorry, the Iran war stuff with Oh, why are
you making this about Israel when the Secretary of State made
it about Israel?
It's It's crazy. >> And also the partner in the war. It's
Yeah. Yeah, it's just You notice this on like every Hasan tweet.
There's just a lot of
a lot of the um the same dog stuff on every Hasan tweet, but
I assume some of it is probably legitimate engagement. Oh, yeah.
I was just laughing that it's like it's the dog thing was This
is it was most of the things that were here when I first looked.
Seems like there's more stuff now, but Yeah. not as quick as
he used to be. That's another thing too is Oak is actually like
not anywhere near as fast. He used to be the first one to get
everything out and now it's
it'll be hours and hours before he's got the clip out.
Too bad. Do you think that Oak was was bought in the beginning?
I mean, you raised that I'm assuming. You've got like a pet theory.
I don't think so.
I don't know what it was that it was more I think
I think it's legitimately
maybe you could say it's two things. I think a lot of streamers
stopped engaging with it as much. Streamers were engaging with
it a lot and then I think as it started hitting you know a lot
of the OTK or even Austin type guys. Like I want to say NMP used
to engage with with some of these tweets. And then I think he
got covered a couple times and he was like, "Uh,
they talk about me." You know what I Only so long you do drama
before you start picking off other people if you're going to
cover all of the drama, right?
Mhm. And then
from there, I think the Hasan is bad stuff has kind of petered
out to some extent. It's not like gone, it's obviously still
there, but it's just not as powerful anymore. Yeah, I probably
agree with that. Yeah. What do you think about the influence
of eating lion? I just feel like that's like continually tanking.
>> Oh, yeah. Dude, he's destroying himself completely.
I don't I don't think I even hear anybody talk about Ethan when
he's not talking about Hasan or entered into like the snark drama
circles anymore. >> Or yeah, the Anisa stuff. Like he I
think people did talk about him with the Anisa thing in the wrong
ways, like laughing at how hard they were sweeping for that clip.
Who is Who is she even trying to sound like here? Who Guys, I
don't know who Who is she even trying to sound That That sounds
crazy.
I totally messed that up as well. I thought that when Nick covered
it, he said that it's not offensive, it's just like a bad impression,
which I still thought was code. I didn't realize that he did
call it He did call it offensive. >> He agreed with the
chatter that it was offensive, yeah. He did. Yep. Oh, wait, he
was arguing about it?
I think apparently on stream today he was arguing about it. Yeah,
with like a Reddit post.
I Let me see if Yeah, please do. No way.
I think somebody may have put it in my inbox. Cuz I maintain
like thoroughly that when you when with this imitation with like
most of the imitations of Ela, you're not really imitating Israeli,
you're imitating like like you're just doing a voice.
Like my actual voice is very, very, very similar. When I'm trying
to make somebody sound stupid when I'm doing like the straw man
voice of somebody,
I'll do like the same voice. So, Okay. Yeah, I think
Okay. So, he wasn't arguing he wasn't arguing about it on stream.
He was arguing on his subreddit
with somebody who was saying that it's not offensive.
Oh. Let me see the link. They are. Check this out. Should Anisa's
impression of Ethan Klein be considered as offensive or anti-Semitic?
I remember Nick said a while back on stream that not only is
it offensive, it's also a bad impression. Personally, I'm quite
conflicted on this position as well. I do agree that her impression
wasn't particularly good. I disagree with the notion that her
impression was
Could accents be considered offensive? All I remember After all,
I remember Nick saying multiple times that we should bring back
accents for comedic reasons. One such example being when Nick
was lamenting that Austin Show/Raj Patel was forced to rebrand
after putting on an Indian accent for years on his Twitch streams
for comedic effect. If Anisa putting on the Israeli accent to
imitate Eli's considered offensive, then by that logic Matan
Even putting on the fake Israeli accent to troll and Sam Hyde
putting on an Irish accent to portray the Candyman should be
considered offensive, too. This his entire response is going
to be, "Well, but those people aren't like considered racist
against those groups. So, that's
That's going to be I feel like that's going to be the cope response.
I haven't I haven't read it yet, but I'm probably the response
is going to be like, "Oh, well, those people don't hold themselves
up to that standards. Those people aren't going to be like woke
scold and tell other people off for being racist." That's going
to be the
I mean, Raj definitely holds himself up to that standard, but
he stopped, I
Sure, sure, sure. Yeah, that'll be a part of it almost certainly.
Heck, we go even one step further and say that Big Bong Cheese's
Trump impressions are offensive, too, while we're at it.
Dude, Big That's not even like in the top 10 list of offensive
things Big Bong Cheese does.
I love Big Bong Cheese videos, by the way, but that's not even
his Trump impressions. Okay.
Well, I think it's absolutely fair to call out Anisa for being
a safe edgy hypocrite by putting on an Israeli accent considering
how she preaches leftist values, but doesn't practice them herself.
Calling the accent itself offensive just doesn't sit right with
me. After all, it doesn't make sense that some
this criticism saying it's offensive is saying it's offensive
to you. It's not offensive because she's a hypocrite. Don't be
a [__] That's not you. Sorry, I'm saying um for Nick.
Uh after all, it doesn't make sense that someone who has said
that we should bring back accents for comedy would then say that
Anisa putting on an Israeli accent is offensive. Am I missing
something here? But I do feel like now he might do the thing
that you did that you said.
Mocking someone's accent / second language speaking is offensive
to most communities partaking in targeting Ela this way. That's
not really an opinion, either. There is a huge double standard
in what people are allowed to ethically mock. So, sure, he's
going to say, "Well, it's she's hypocritical." But he didn't
say she's being hypocritical.
He said that's offensive. >> it to those communities using
it to mock
That's a that's like a collective punishment hypocrisy. That's
offensive. That's offensive. >> not even you, not even
you, but the communities that you're from might find that offensive.
They don't, actually. I I tweeted that clip and that the communities
that she's from found that hilarious, okay?
That's not even true.
Uh the caveat is that it's fair game to do this if the person
is hated enough. Okay, fair enough. In Anisa have moved on from
edge lords to woke scolds, but constantly fall back on tactics
they used before. No bad tactics, only bad targets in it. You
Your take manages to get all the way there and wrap back around
to something I never said on what amounts to little more than
a throwaway line.
No, that's not true. He's just got to He's just I mean, he's
got He could do this in his subreddit, right? He's just lying
about what he said.
Cuz that that is important, right? He didn't He didn't go out
of his way to say, "Well, actually, that should be They should
find that offensive, but she's doing this accents blah blah blah
blah blah." He didn't do anything like that. He just went, "That's
offensive." Yeah, which is a different criticism.
It is. It is, yeah. Oh, man. But, it's the criticism that people
give um like Ian and Hila Hassan
every time that like to their
it would or should be offensive, and so that's like an indictment
on them.
Like, "Ooh, I don't think that I don't think the lefties on Twitter
are going to like this."
As if that's like anything. As if that's like anything to say.
Also, don't think that's true. Like, Raj is in those communities
to begin with. The guy you're literally pointing out is the guy
who's awesome for doing the
He's literally in those communities.
He um I mean iDubbbz is in those communities. Are those people
like Are those people okay with saying like epsilon or the other
way around? >> No, but I I actually don't think Raj would
be thrown out for the Indian accent. But, also, Hassan does accents
all the Hassan loves doing Hassan will take a million different
subs at a million different races' accents.
I don't know why people are pretending that doesn't happen all
the time.
I assume we think he's the figurehead of these communities. Yeah.
I mean, like I said, I think it's like
collective collective hypocrisy. But, it's just the idea of what
community would would like. Yeah, yeah. I think there's a reply
down as well if you scroll down.
If you go to deleted account.
Yeah, there you go. Open that bad boy
Less grifting, more just beating a dead horse because it's super
easy and very profitable. Also, part of his likely just audience
capture. A lot of his current fans are H3 fans, so he's probably
more inclined to pull his punches a bit more often even when
he's criticizing them.
None of my punches are pulled. The opinions stated are mine.
I also run it concurrently with their 4,000 plus viewer promoted
aftershow most nights. If crossover viewers were going to leave,
it would be one of the numerous issues that I've had that I've
disagreed with. It would be on one of the numerous issues I've
disagreed with. For example, stating that Hasan [__]
wasn't calling for the death of Ela.
Mhm, fair enough.
Sorry, that wasn't me trying to straw man to do like the straw
man voice to make him sound goofy. That was me doing a genuine
attempt at a Nick impression. So. You're such a liar.
I'm not sure I'm not lying. That was me actually trying to do
his voice as best I could.
His voice is very high-pitched.
It just objectively is. HIS VOICE IS HIGH-PITCHED. WHAT AM I
SUPPOSED to do? Next time I do a Kermit the Frog Jordan Peterson
to try and do your Canadian accent. That's what I'll say as well.
That's what I'll say as well. Hey, I [clears throat] sound like
Kermit the Frog or Jordan Peterson. What am I supposed to do?
Pretend I don't?
Look, I'm already a thousand times bigger than in in a moral
sense than Nicholas DeOrio and Hila Klein or Ethan Klein, sorry.
Okay? I can admit what I sound like. Why can't she admit she
sounds like [__]
Why can't she admit she sounds like [laughter] Barney from The
Simpsons,
She does make little like Lurch sounds every once in a while.
And then when she laughs, too, it's uh a lot. >> Yeah.
I mean, I I just don't
Like I don't think that Nick Dude, I just think Nick does not
talk about Ethan and Ela in a way that he talk about any random
normal person. He feels pretty dedicated to that cause, to that
side of the issue. I mean, if you can say he can maybe try and
say he's being like fair,
I think that would be like an acceptable argument for like for
his perspective. But to say that none of them are pulled, I think
you've obviously got like a bias towards them. That feels like
a reflexively defensive thing to say.
Uh yeah.
>> Like they were trying to paint out Hasan as advocating
for somebody's death.
That's the discernment that he had
Yeah, I think Like psychotic, paranoid, crazy, vindictive, spiteful.
It's in target selection, right? Like it's in the thing Basically,
when I think Ethan does something like wrong,
low-level wrong, he's just never going to cover it. But when
Hasan does something low-level wrong, Idubbbz does something
low-level wrong, he'll cover it to death, right? And he'll like
make a big deal out of it. And so you just end up with something
where it seems biased, where it is biased, really. But it's just
in that like if a like a, you know, three or four out of five,
sorry, three or four out of 10
dramatic thing happens or goofy things happen that he could cover,
for Ethan, he'll like kind of just not or not really make a big
deal out of it. And then if it's with Hasan or Idubbbz, he could
turn that into like a six or a seven out of 10. I think that's
that's where like the bias would come in. It's not that he's
stating opinions that he doesn't have or defending Ethan over
like really petty [__] and or taking really big [__]
making it small. I think it's all in selection and how he's been
More than like him lying about something. But it I mean that's
kind of >> commentary people though.
Well, that I'm literally describing like
Like I know I like this mini falling out with like Destiny months
before I left that whole scene, right? And I know that I just
went and I started like stalking Hasan cuz I had like the community
overlap and I'm like, "Well, I'm not going to like get super
about that. I'm just going to go do my own thing." And I know
I just focused on Hasan, right? If I don't want to go and talk
about this person, I know I can focus on someone else and make
it entertaining. I think that's what Nick does. He just doesn't
focus on Ethan. Slightly different reasons, but I think it's
pretty easy to figure out why someone would do that, right?
Uh, yeah. Yeah. Also, I
Does he
If crossover views going to leave, what are one of the numerous
issues that I've disagreed with? I just don't think that Nick
does disagree the way that would even be
for crossover views to leave.
I I want to find a disagreement where he doesn't go, "I totally
understand like why they think that." And I want to find a crossover
an issue like this where he doesn't go, "I totally understand
why they think that and I am sympathetic to why they think that
and I, you know, I get it but I disagree." Do you know what I
mean where he doesn't like soften it a million times that it's
like I
I get it. I'm going to make sure you feel like I understand you.
I do think that does happen a lot.
Or it's just even in the phrasing like
>> it doesn't it's like using non-essentializing
language.
Like it's not an issue with them, it's an issue with their action.
Do you know what I mean? They've made a mistake. I think they've
really screwed up this one, you know, something like that,
Sure, sure, sure. Yeah.
What do you mean? It's just like it's I think that's fine for
anybody to be able to be able to admit. Like when you were covering
something and you take one side of something, you're almost sympathetic
almost sympathetic to one side. And you've got a personal back
and forth between you and them, you are going to treat them like
a slightly different way. Yeah, I don't know why you should waste
time going into these Reddit arguments and making your points
clear.
How do you think things things stand
Pull it back with the whole commentary community now.
After the Chud Logic debacle with Nick. Now the dust has settled.
I don't know.
Has Chud been I feels like Chud's been taking a little time off
recently.
I wanted to say that.
No, I think you're right. Yeah, he's been dealing with like house
stuff.
Yeah. Like I noticed his viewership the past like 2 days was
not as good as it was before, but I think that's cuz drama's
super dry and like he's just watching like very long um retrospective
videos and [__]
But I don't think he like was significantly hurt in audience.
Like I think most of the damage from the Nick fallout happened
before.
And I don't think Nick is in a better place either. I think they
it was kind of neutral.
Um in terms of like overall fallout, I don't know. Did you get
any other impression from that that it was like worse than that?
Or different? >> I mean it is tough to say cuz um after
Chud had uh like the fallout with Nick, he was sorting out his
house as well. I feel like this there is going to be some kind
of impact.
I feel like there is going to be some kind of impact.
Chud's viewership was like up after the fallout. Like but not
even just from covering the fallout. Like it was up after the
fallout with a lot of the stuff that was getting covered after
the fallout, I think. And then
I think he started to I think he then had to go and do other
[__] And I think he was missing days or something.
I don't know. I He He unfortunately streams like right when I
go to sleep, so I end up missing quite a bit of his stuff. >> I
could [clears throat] be wrong. I just don't want to say anything
that's um that's from not looking at his numbers too much. I
just feel as though there has been like a certain certain amount
of damage there. Like Chud knows that he's got
or did have overlap with the with Keemstar and even though even
though they don't stream over each other. I feel like Nick is
actors that he's so hot and Chud's the next John Swan. I mean
what what a Nick viewer is going to do with that, right? They're
probably going to jump ship.
Yeah, but I
I want to go and see >> a calculation on both sides of
how many viewers have have decided, as a matter of protest, that
they're not going to watch that person. Or even for like a livestream
or like personalities who are important, how many people have
like their view of Chud has changed and now they they watch the
content. Yeah, I think it's like a numbers game on both sides,
but I don't think that anybody from Chud's chat watched Nick.
I think people from Nick's chat did watch Chud. And so I feel
like just cuz of the numbers there,
like Chud is just more liable to damage. I know what you're saying.
I do feel like Chud was carrying numbers quite well for a while.
And then yeah, it's just um
quite a few days of like not streaming.
Like the I I literally just pulled it up cuz I was interested.
But you see, like when I see this many like off days for somebody
like Chud who does the um like he was streaming for a while every
single day and then he went to a 5-day
I see just like quite a few breaks in
Like yeah, your your average is going to
decent amount off of this. You know what I'm saying?
But I also think his Kick stream and Kick chat has been taking
off more as well. So it's hard to say
how much of this is lost versus bleed over to Kick, which probably
financially helps him.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah, that's a good point.
But I Yeah, I I agree with you that it could be that he lost
some viewers to
Is it like
Yeah, I I guess he'll be the one who knows or the one who like
Cuz like if he >> speak to it.
If you just think about it, I feel like a lot of people on this
side watched Diorio talking about Chud and just thought like,
"Dude, this guy's like super hysterical." [snorts]
Like he's playing this up so much. He sounds like such a [__]
But I I doubt that's how Nick's viewers watched like saw it,
you know? I'm pretty sure they probably like totally bought him.
Maybe. I I guess I just don't have a good sense of Nick's viewer
base. Like at all almost. You know what I'm saying? Cuz like
I Dude, Nick's stream is watchable to me. I've I've like tried
I try to react to his stream sometimes. It
Not even
I'll I'll be honest, it's like 80% unwatchable because of the
donation spam and how uh like how annoying it is, but even just
him, like he is actually
I just I don't like it. It's like a mix
a like a lack of substance and he's just not funny to me at all.
That might just be personal distaste, but yeah, it's like unwatchable
as a stream. Yeah, I I feel that's like personality playing into
it, maybe, but I don't know.
It could be. It could be, but that's the kind of that I think
would play against Chud and Nick's audience.
>> Yeah, I think it's more than personality. It's like
I've had a few of the like tropes for how he does humor pointed
out to me and now I can't unsee them. Like when he's doing his
Family Guy references, that's like the time when this happened.
You know what I'm like, once you once it's pointed out to you,
it's like It's like you know those things that you get it pointed
out and it just >> it becomes formulaic, yeah. It's yeah.
So, that might be
that might be what it is more than cuz it I didn't personally
dislike Nick for like a long time.
But I still couldn't really do the stream. Somebody asked or
somebody wanted to point out that Chud was crying also. What
about the Nick Bridges >> I'm pretty sure that Chud was
just laughing the entire way through, no? Like if anything, Chud
was treating it with more levity than that he probably should.
Like Chud was moving his lips. >> But was he bitching about
>> DramaAlert Drama 101 person to join this
I don't know who it is for sure, but I've narrowed it down to
like five people in my mind and I just want them to join. Just
let's hear the voice Drama 101. Come on the stream Drama 101.
I feel like we got a She's got an avatar.
Nope. I mean, regardless of whether in fact Chud was crying or
not, uh that's a very high percentage reaction, actually. I was
trying to remember what I said. Yeah, so what I said was that
a lot of people on this side complain that Nick was crying. How
much do you think that affected Nick's viewers who did actually
buy into it? So, it's not even an analysis of the drama. It's
about how an audience perceive it. Yeah. Maybe they hate Nick
and they're trying to they're trying to argue, "Yeah, Chud was
crying, too. Chud was crying as well. Nick's going to go down
any day now."
People are going to believe it anyway. >> They're just
saying that you are you're pointing out that Nick's crying and
not that Chud was crying or something. They're definitely just
saying you're being biased or something. I A better way like
maybe a better way that person could understand it or a different
way that person could understand it is Nick made a lot of appeals
for sympathy
from his audience in a way that I don't believe Chud did.
Chud Chud wasn't appealing for sympathy from his audience. He
was going, "Yeah, I know I'm a [__] loser. I know
I'm a [__] loser for like uh like doing this this
way, for for talking about my feelings and stuff."
And Nick was like, "This guy stabbed me in the
He stabbed me in the neck!"
Like a little bit of a different way of engaging with the audience.
And I do think >> did did betray him though, to be fair.
Yeah. Which Which part was the worst part of the betrayal in
your opinion? Probably betraying Ethan Klein.
I feel like Ethan Klein has given Chud like the other half of
his audience and now he's just turning tail on him. I That was
one of my favorite collabs, the Chud Logic
Klein collab.
That was good. Yeah, that was good.
Uh I'll be honest, um I'm up like super past my bedtime right
now. Thank you so much for coming on. I feel like I got to I'm
fading so badly and thank you for coming on.
I'm dying dying.
>> Drama 101
in chat. What voice channel do I join?
They're They're Their hands are Their hands are
are quivering as they're typing. >> The waiting room. The
waiting room. Join the waiting room. I just want to hear this
person join the waiting room drama 101. I don't have somebody
called drama 101 in my Discord. So, I do want to see who it is.
We'll see. We'll see if they're going to join really quick. Oh,
I don't think he's going to
What's up?
Oh, no. There they are. Oh, this is the iron hippie person.
Oh, I'm not Never mind. This is a different person than I thought.
Sorry. I really want to talk to them.
Yeah, [laughter] I thought I thought this was going to be somebody
else. I just want to hear Hold on. Let's hear the voice. Just
say hello. Yo, what up?
Can you hear me?
Yeah, I can hear you. Yeah, I didn't know I didn't know who you
thought I was.
You think it might be a voice changer?
Can I get some Can I get some reading from this guy real quick?
Can you Can you just open some text up? Hold on. Can you read
this for me? You need to read this for me. >> Even the
screenshot?
Yep. Yep. Yep. >> Read out?
And what happened to I saw perfectly
refrain on it's just Judaism. Whatever. Okay, you [snorts] passed
the test.
I haven't decided yet. Listen, I'm I'm like really tired. Thank
you everybody for being here tonight. I do have to end the stream
or I'm going to pass out and die, okay?
Thank you everybody for Iron Hippie. Thank you for coming on.
You've You've proven that you're not somebody who I could have
possibly thought you were. But, I kind of knew that the second
you joined with this I should have just asked you your Discord
name. That would have been way easier for me. But, thanks for
coming
Have a good night. I'll talk to you guys later. See you. Yeah,
we'll talk to you later. See you.
Oh my goodness. So late. It's so late. I got to go to sleep.
Guys, thank you for being here. I'm ending.
I will be back tomorrow probably. almost certainly. Have a good
night everybody. Thank you.
Bye. Bye. Bye.